how you guys been how you guys been
doing yeah good good this episode's
coming out the week we record it so
that's so we decided to talk to make
another topical episode most recent
you'll see us yeah and I guess like one
of the most recent topical things that
has happened not just like in the
previous like two weeks but it seems to
we keep happening now is uh YouTubers
ruining Japan that is not us hey w we
start we we started we actually actually
no let's let's let's give out let's give
our shout out to the OG Logan Paul for
starting off the trends only time you
get such a good job that Chris had to go
on national TV and uh coin the iconic a
YouTuber to apologize and show that
YouTubers are kind of normal something
he's a trend Ser yeah well where where
is Chris now where we need him most on
on National Television to tell everyone
that YouTubers aren't bad yeah uh but
yeah so that yeah that's been a big
thing obviously there's the the famous
one with Johnny SM which we didn't talk
about and I didn't talk about it at all
and I think most of us didn't because we
didn't want to give him more ATT
attention while he was still it seemed
like he kind of thrived off getting
attention on and causing all these like
terrible kind of oh trust me I would
have made 10 second Channel videos on
him but then I thought to myself no this
is exactly what he wants and I guess
this is exactly what he wants he was
fueling off it and then now obviously
he's been uh arrested and twice twice
yeah because Japan has this I mean it's
actually kind of terrifying it's a
really weird system uh they can hold you
for 28 days is maybe correct 28 or 24
can't remember honey uh and then before
they have to charge you with anything
obviously in in most Western countries
the UK and us I think it's 24 or 48
hours I think it's 48 before they have
to charge you with anything so it's kind
of terrifying that they can like in
Japan they can they can hold you for 28
days they can ruin your life because you
know you don't if you don't show up to
work you can't talk to anyone you you
can't contact anyone except your lawyer
um uh and so you're in the system and
then they have this amazing thing that
they can do which I don't know how
they're allowed to do this this is
insane to me if you don't get charged in
that period they can just charge you
with something else the moment that
period is up which is what they're doing
right now
which listen it's a it's a some some
people Karma hits very get well for but
sometimes you're like man I wish the
system wasn't [__] though as well but
you're like damn but it is nice to see
when the [__] system is kind of used
in a in a kind of useful way to Target
someone who's just a SC Scourge on the
earth so so if you don't know who Johnny
SMY is if you are not in tune with I
guess the streamer culture uh good on
you but yeah he was a streamer that blew
up on Kick a while ago he yeah yeah Ki
he got banned from the other platforms I
believe yeah I I believe he got banned
from the other platforms and he made a
name for himself by basically going out
to the streets of Japan and uh to put it
simply harassing people just straight up
just straight up if if you'd heard about
one of those guys who are like just
shouting Hiroshima and Nagasaki in the
middle of a [__] tr I just remember I
did make a video on that first incident
you the first guy the first one where he
was on the train and he was blasting
music and then God like and then he went
up to a random just innocent salary man
in Japan and was just like Hiroshima
Nagasaki do you remember it we'll do it
again I [__] tell you and I'm like
what do you have like government
connections like what how what where is
this confidence coming from the sad
thing with that guy is everyone was like
wow I'm sure he's just a tourist like no
he's been living here eight years yeah
and then doesn't speak any Japanese and
then also um I guess was like a
40-year-old man essentially he was oh no
no no that's a different one what yeah
yeah yeah that's a different one you're
talking about the other the guy who's
like blasting scrx why why is there so
many of them that's so that was the
first one I did I didn't mention him by
name and I'm still not going to cuz he
deserves no attention but then I
actually did do the first Johnny
Somalian s where he talked about the
Hiroshima Nagasaki [__] well that was
bad cuz like that immediately made news
in Japan yeah yeah and uh naturally yeah
that one was that one was interesting
that was where uh listen uh Japanese
people online if you if you if they you
give them a reason to think that they
can say what they want to say holy [__]
did they say some heinous [__] the
comments I was seeing were [__] awful
yeah if you thought if you thought
forchan was bad you've never been on I
I've never seen such I mean I've been
I've seen a western thing holy [__] the
open racism was crazy on the jaese side
uh cuz they just felt justified in being
racist in a way you know that's you know
that's the one reason when I decided to
move to Japan I didn't make a Japan like
Japanese channel oh okay well I because
I was like cuz I used to be on tchan
when I was in high school cuz I was dumb
as [__] and I had too much time on my
hands and I saw my God it made it made
the new grounds forums look like a
playground like it was it was bad and I
was like well if I say anything bad
they're going to take one look at this
face and they go stupid guy Jin probably
the tamest thing they'll say and then
they'll just cancel me off the face of
the Earth over nothing probably but this
one was uh definitely this whole jie
Somali thing and all the other ones he
was involved he was inciting action and
violence there was venty of plenty of
incidents where you know he just like
get punched by random people on the
streets yeah I think Australian dude who
knocked out his friend and then him
which was which was great he's doing the
Aussies crowd to see and you know like
this is coming straight out of just
finishing Vinland Saga season 2 where
you're like I have no enemies and you're
like wait though violence actually
I don't condone it's it's that moment
where you're like so I don't condone
violence but but it is kind of uh
expected when you do stuff like like
yeah he probably watched Vinland Saga
and was like I have no enemies and he
was just like
that I mean it's easy
to feel no ill will towards people until
there's someone like that in front of
you where you're like actually I I do
hate some people I think some people
suck some people deserve a punch in the
face you know and so obviously he kept
pushing it uh TR was just doing straight
bun of crimes on camera and then got
arrested and that was cool and then um
recently there was um so the the thought
process I think currently with um J SM I
think they are going to charge him with
something obviously Japan has I think
again this is all like I think I know
this but I'm not 100% sure if you are a
foreigner or foreign National in Japan
and you get charged with over one year
of a crime you are automatically
deported mhm so if you get over a year
sentence they just instead of serving it
in Japan why would the [__] would they
want to deal with you they just send you
out if it's less than a year I think you
serve it in Japan yeah and I think he
got arrested because he snuck into a
construction site trespassing was the
first one and the second one was and
then he was harassing the world it was
being a nuisance in business which is is
super vague yeah and I feel like any of
us could be like if you go in anywhere
with a camera you could be arrested of
that it's kind of a very it's a little
it's I will admit on the the Japanese
side they are they are grasping straws
to keep this man in jail and it's I mean
for this scenario you're like oh this is
great but also it's kind of scary at the
same time that you're like if you just
piss off the wrong government person you
could just be in jail for whatever
[__] reason yeah I mean it's it's
scary but at the same time it's it was
kind of like you know this was this is
the bare definition of [__] around and
find out he he was uh [__] around as
much as he possibly could uh and he
found out and the that worries me is
that this will set the wrong kind of
like expectations in president because I
saw like it's it's rare that a western
kind of like content creator makes news
in the Japanese spere he even like for a
good reason yeah yeah yeah exactly well
another another streamer was um in in
jail for 30 days but wasn't charged with
anything because they were trespassing
uh I think I don't know if they were
streaming but they were at the Fukushima
nuclear exclusion Zone oh yeah I
remember this um but that was that that
didn't get nearly as much backlash as
this did which is kind of crazy in a in
a weird way because it's why do you
think that is I just think the nuisance
he was just he was such an easy person
to hate the Japanese or it was the
Japanese public just being like don't
worry the radiation will get him
eventually no we don't have to doy so we
don't have
to so we don't have to do anything no
cuz that doing so nature is taking its
course well wait okay that's that's a
that's an insult to everyone
okay okay if if if I'm just joking look
look look I like I I I know why okay
because like trespassing it's just like
eh doesn't really affect me you see a
clip of someone being loud on the train
and I think Japanese people are like we
found pu number one that is very visual
for Japanese it goes It goes against
everything the Japanese have build on
and then he starts shouting out
Hiroshima and Nagasaki being a public
nuisance you know this like here is the
complete antithesis of what [__] like
Japan as a Society except especially in
public you know absolutely yeah um uh
yeah uh it'll be interesting to see how
it all plays out yeah because we had
like this the other YouTuber I don't
know if you saw this about a guy who
went around Japan and he was like the
YouTuber the YouTube video I believe was
like how I traveled around Japan for
free y the most recent one yeah yeah
okay first of all though this guy's
YouTube channel I don't want to name it
but he has this one thumbnail where it's
like I survived the poorest place on
Earth and it's just like a white dude
surrounded by like 20 black kids and
it's like what is this you are you are a
human plague you are you are
insufferable you are so [__] useless
you you provide less to humanity than
the Barnacles on shipping boats you are
such a useless person that's one of
those thumbnails I just wish you were
joking about you know it's like it's so
[__] up that like it's it's insane you
didn't make that up you know yeah I the
like the zero level of awareness as a
human being to upload that and be like
I'm okay with this blows my mind but
yeah so he he he did uh it was like 11
days I think or something in the video
like a week he did all we did with uh
our video which is traveling from like
the most southern point of Japan to the
most northern point he definitely faked
90% of it cuz he sneaks getting on the
bullet train and if you ever been on a
bullet train you can't do that there's
absolutely no shot he's pulling that off
there's there's you might be able to
maybe get through the gate but it would
be so tough it's not the New York subway
you can't just like jump the gate
willly it is like there are at least
like in most like major train stations
where you can get the shin g s there's
at least like two or three dudes who are
there making sure you get on yeah
there's one train that you don't want to
even attempt [__] around with and
trying to pull that [__] on that one you
will 100% get caught it's like trying to
sneak on a plane you know it's like it
it just doesn't it doesn't happen it's
very very like tough so I believe he cuz
even in the video he just happens to
spawn on the train and obviously clearly
fake but one thing he did do is that I
think he he the thing that pissed me off
most about this video is he was just
begging Japanese people for money when
he was already like making money from
this video and you know people people it
it just sucks to know that a lot of
people here really push themselves and
and work horrible working hours for
really bad pay uh and then some [__]
[__] comes along as something for
like $20 get and then just makes a th000
off it anyway yeah and I think he
definitely knew that that is like a very
like Japanese thing to do which is like
obviously try and help others especially
a foreigner in somewhere like Tokyo
right where like there are probably a
lot of foreigners who come to like these
big cities don't know how to get around
and you know maybe ask you know for like
directions and sometimes maybe even ask
for like some change or whatever right
so like and the the whole idea of like
you know Japanese people like helping
out the Greater Community or helping out
you know others being a Good Samaritan
is very like ingrained in a lot of
Japanese people's minds I think most
people will help you out if they you
have no money and so taking advantage of
that to make a video which you are going
to make money off of anyway also aiding
this person intoing illegal [__] is just
the most scummy [__] thing you can do
yeah and and that obviously made news in
Japan as well was pretty popular it's
just frustrating because it's like okay
a lot of goodwi that has been built up
from humans in general it's like oh
let's just squander we're out here
fighting the [__] good fight making
sure foreigners get a good name for
themselves here and then just a couple
of we go through so much red tape like
fighting tooth and nail fighting for our
lives just to get permission filming in
a place all it takes us one person bring
it all down because like I mean
obviously there's like I think the thing
that pissed me off right is it's not
just like okay his like Africa video of
course it was like what you what you
would call a dick move right but then
there's there's like there's like I with
the Japan video he's just straight up
breaking laws yeah right I'm yeah I
think at one point in the video he gets
on the bus and does he gets on the bus
and just refuses to pay and then just
gets like uh escorted to the police
station or something like that yeah I
think he thought they were going to drop
it cuz it was 80 yen in the video was he
had begged someone for 500 600 Yen or
something and the fair was 680 Yen so
it's about like a 50 Cent 40 Cent
difference and I I think in the video he
thought he was just going to drop it but
that's not it's not how it works you
can't you can't barter and worst maybe
the best case scenario for you the bus
driver might feel so sorry for you is
like a pathe human cockroach that you
are and he' give you the ADN to pay but
then it's like even then it's like like
none of these scenarios make you like a
a a human being that is nice or has any
productive uh Tendencies at all I just
think you're just piece of [__] yeah
there wasn't a single person who looked
at that and was like oh you know it's so
nice for the bus driver to like you know
spare him that asense change you know
he's probably living a hard life no in
Japan it's probably like can't cough it
up [__] you yeah pretty much you're not
getting off that's you follow by the
rules in this country and if you don't
follow by the rules then you're
[__] and yeah like you say just it
pisses me off when you get you see
someone or you see like conent creatures
kind of like taking advantage of the
Goodwill of just like one how
non-confrontational Japanese people are
right cuz it's it's like sometimes you
see this in other countries and you're
like oh there is no way there is no shot
some of this content would be gotten
away with if you film this in America or
something if I ever saw a video like
this in the UK i' be like I'm not
worried if he pulled that [__] on
someone I'm sure someone would he'd [__]
around and find out exactly exactly
right which is like why I think a lot of
people are like H I don't care if he
does this anywhere else it's like here
is like for [__] sake like don't what
are you doing these people these people
are too nice to you is it is you're a
human plague yeah yeah exactly and you
know it's we we've we've we talk from
experience when we've gone through
enough red tape and red Hoops not you
Joe but even to get like visas to work
here uh and trying to instill something
new like a new idea to like especially
like older Japanese people and it just
it it's so annoying when I see the
coverage that these kinds of like
content creators get where there is so
many people out there that are trying to
do things the right way that have been
trying to do things the right way I mean
I can't imagine anyone who's more pissed
about this than Chris is you know
considering how much he's worked to
change the perspective of YouTubers and
conat in Japan ab and and that's the
shitty thing right is that like negative
press is always going to just have a
wider attraction you know no matter
where the country or the culture is and
it's definitely the case here because
you know people like Chris and people
like you know us can do the best things
for the country and you know try and put
a positive impact on how Japanese people
especially the older generation not only
just view content creators like
YouTubers and twitch streamers but also
just like foreigners living here trying
to make an honest living in general All
For You know what a p on the back you
know maybe less [__] talking behind the
scenes meanwhile you you do one [__]
bad thing and you get your face plased
on the front page of NHK you know do do
you think these kind do you think we're
going to continue see more of these
kinds of people oh God I hope not um but
I think so sadly sadly I think it's
going to happen because I think these
two examples especially have just shown
there have been multiple examples like
we've talked about but uh you get
instant views if you do the sh in Japan
if you did this [__] in Florida you
you'd be the least insane person in
Florida so like it just doesn't you
don't you don't get anything out of
the scary thing is I think what's what
might happen I really hope this doesn't
happen is not only are there going to be
more people who are doing this in Japan
but there are going to be more people
are just doing this in Asia in general
yeah you know cuz I think like it's
already you know the kind of a an idea
as you said like you know if you did
that in places like the UK or America no
one would bat an ey no one [__] gives
a [__] it's a no one gives a [__] but if
you do it in a country like Asia where
like the way that the culture operates
is different and it's you know [__]
something else for people to see of like
oh you know how would you be able to do
it in Korea or how would you be able to
do it in like Thailand you know I think
the concern has been that they might try
and pass some laws around it um but I I
I don't know it's Japan's very weird
about passing laws they either do it
really fast stealthily or they make a
big public 10 years 10 years we might do
it we're thinking about it hey guys what
do you think like and sometimes it just
doesn't happen I I don't I don't know
what they could change um because I it's
if they could do a law that was like
only foreigners are not allowed to do it
they'd do it
they but uh I I think because YouTube is
is is really well built up in Japan I
think Japanese YouTubers have have been
very very mainstream for a very long
time and have been have been making
YouTube seem like a much more kind of um
I think yoube yeah viable platform yeah
and I think in some senses like Japan
has really adopted YouTube culture
really well its own sense so I don't
think they would be very very very
hastily rushing through something Half
Baked I think if they were to do
something they'd figure it out because I
think right now the way that filming in
public works in Japan is that you can
you can film in public um if it's uh
without needing to blur any one or do
anything like that if it's not for
commercial purposes but obviously if it
is it's a lot more complicated and yeah
you have to get permission stuff like
that it's kind of it's kind of tough
it's it's really weird spot right now
yeah and like I I don't know I think
there should be at least a line drawn in
the Sand by the actual platforms uh if
you break a law and you you film it
surely that is like yeah I mean there's
a platform now that just invited all
that in so it's kind of hard I think
you'd think the platforms would do
better I I'm surprised YouTube they only
just took down his video I'm surprised
it didn't do yeah why is it why is it
that like people get a pass when it's
filmed but they don't get a pass when
it's not filmed like how does that it's
so bizarre with with um YouTube and how
they enforce their rules cuz like
sometimes they'll be so strict on
someone and they'll clamp down and other
people they get like a slap on the wrist
obviously with their whole uh doxing
situation of recent oh yeah that's that
was like one there it was like okay
YouTube this is a really weird stance to
take and also took forever yeah um it's
it's really odd how these platforms
really are very slow to the the the ball
sometimes they need to stop playing
favoritism right which is impossible
task to ask it's like I I think
obviously I think they are doing
something kind of right because I've
seen what happens when you go the kind
of like opposite direction and there
when there are clear biases with a
platform like twitch you know where you
try to please a certain amount of
creators and you piss off everyone in
the process you know because I I yeah I
think because sometimes you know on
Twitch um and other I guess twitch more
so because twitch is a bit more personal
in this less big creators because
YouTube has so many creators YouTube has
so many creators huge right and there
are a lot of creators who bring in there
are I think like tens of thousands of
creators who bring in over a million
dollars of Revenue a year which are a
lot of people that bring in a
substantial amount of money right and
and none of these people you want to
take away all their ads from cuz that's
a lot of money that YouTube loses that
YouTube needs cuz holy [__] does YouTube
cost a lot of money to run but twitch
like I've noticed that like you
definitely if you're a creator that is
bigger and you have a very good track
record you definitely get the benefit of
the doubt with certain things or they'll
be like okay just be careful next time
yeah um because you do you have that
track record and you are a bit more
favorable but
obviously if you it's such a fine thing
to to do that because if you give too
much leeway then a lot of the audience
from other audiences that might see this
might be like what the [__] Conor got
his [__] out why isn't he banned um
that's [__] up I think there's a case
that people were really calling for a
band recently where a streamer was
driving while texting uh and they were
kind of like a they had a very good R
yeah um and it took a little while for
them to get the ban but I think everyone
unanimously was like they should get a
ban for this that's just dangerous um
and I think if that didn't happen and I
think it only happened because of the
sheer amount of like people being like
you have to give this person a band
there's an horrible press the community
pressure right yeah but I think if the
pressure wasn't there I don't think it
would have happened because it took like
two or three days for the band to come
through if I recall correctly I mean you
know there there's a lot of instances of
like a Creator you know YouTube twitch
or whatever doing something that is very
questionable sometimes just straight up
you
know yeah caught red-handed and it's not
until it gets enough attention from the
community whether that be on like
Twitter or you know just YouTube in
general to for YouTube to finally be
like oh they did a bad thing
oh uh yeah okay we we'll do what you
guys said thanks thanks for letting us
know it really depends I don't really
fully understand how it works but I I've
just noticed that sometimes you get you
get a little Goodwill here and there
yeah but it's just how it works right it
reminds me of like that one Tik tocker a
while ago he was like British I believe
uh who just like filmed himself breaking
and entering into like people's houses
and stealing dogs and just like
literally committing crimes to the point
where he got arrested and like he was in
court and the judge asked him if he was
going to do it again he was like yeah
yeah and they he did yeah and like the
problem is like the problem is somehow
someone like this who is clearly like
not even like being a dick but just like
breaking laws this is a new level now
this is like someone is breaking the
laws of the country you're in and uh
they can get away with it just because
cuz Tik Tok looked at and went like yeah
but do you see how many [__] views
this get though see that that one uh
these kids in America were filming
themselves uh doing hit and runs what
and they they killed a police officer
cuz they hit him on a bicyc oh I heard
about this they filming it and then when
they got arrested they were like nah
it's not that serious though right oh
yeah yeah I think I think I saw this
yeah yeah and like what